c'est une première dans le domaine des
opérateurs on en reçoit un couple mais
c'est myriam et pierre bonsoir déjà
comme ça la photo elle est même fait
très beau tous les deux alors thiery
eelv est arrivé un drame le en 2015 13
novembre
tout le monde sait à la la tout le monde
sait le 13 novembre à 20h45 50 ce qu'il
faisait ses lauriers cette fameuse un
tas de du bataclan vous étiez où j'étais
dans la salle en salle vous avez vu la
mort j'ai rien vu rien vu en plus
changeant même j'ai eu de la chance
non en fait je me suis pris une balle
assez rapidement dans la prend dans le
au début de l'attaqué
je préfère un black-out donc en fait
j'ai rien vu de ce qui s'est passé mais
je me suis réveillé après donc j'ai rien
vu pas conscience de ce que vous avez
vécu pas conscient de ce qui se passait
rien du tout et avec le recul
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est plus
compliqué quand on a vécu les choses
sans les vies finalement ça en fait ça
permet de ne pas déjà avoir souvenir de
quoi que ce soit donc ça c'est pratique
et de ça permet de se projeter et tout
et c'est ce qu'on fait en fait depuis
cinq ans six ans et on se projette et on
a plein de projets aujourd'hui et ont
vite ça donc c'est c'est bien plus un
pas de vis à vis comme ça que se
replonger dans le passé
portrait c'est parti il s'appelle myriam
et pierre ils sont passionnés de voyages
depuis toujours pourtant le couple va
vivre une terrible épreuve qui va
changer leurs vies lors des attentats du
bataclan le 13 novembre 2015
moi j'ai absolument rien contre 1
importe contre qui que ce soit j'ai pas
envie de retenir afin de toujours devoir
me dire penser me raccrocher à quelque
chose ce soir de tragédies pierre est
gravement touché par une balle au niveau
de la moelle épinière
contrairement à certains il va s'en
sortir mais il dit
présent se déplacer en fauteuil roulant
une épreuve difficile pour le couple
mais qui ne stoppera pas leur rêve de
parcourir le monde puisque en 2018 ils
vont même créé wild world qui permet à
toutes les personnes en situation de
handicap de pouvoir voyager et vous
allez quand même chose si myriam et
pierre venait d'entamer un tour du monde
de 14 mois la crise sanitaire est venue
stopper leur périple
mais contre eux prendre la route dès que
possible en attendant une escale sur
notre plateau ce soir pour notre plus
grand plaisir
alors vivre ensemble
forcément on est en couple tout va bien
la vie se déroule tranquillement un
concert un drame un attentat tout
bascule comment est-ce qu'on se
reconstruit comment est ce qu'on
continue son aventure ensemble ça c'est
franchement c'est ce que les gens se
demandent s'il faisait que cinq mois
qu'on est ensemble
ce jour là vous savez moi cinq mois j'ai
fait 4 mariages et non en fait au bout
de ses seins de ses cinq mois moi quand
je me suis réveillé je me suis rendu
compte que j'avais pas changé d'état
d'esprit j'avais pas eu d'impact en fait
psychologique de ce qui s'était passé et
ça nous a permis de commencer une
reconstruction petit à petit donc il ya
eu à l'hôpital la reconstruction j'étais
aux invalides dans paris est en fête
entourée comme on l'a été avec nos
proches et avec myriam mais en fait ça
nous a permis d'aller de nous projeter
ne voir en fait que la vie m'a vu khoan
avec une c'était pas mal de la vivre à
fond quoi alors je gère une question qui
qui est un peu dur mais myriam vous
connais vous revendez cahill et il est
valide
il ya ce drame c'est notre homme qu'est
ce qui fait qu on alors or est-ce qu'on
continue qu'on poursuivre que c'est
l'amour ultime est ce que c'est la
preuve d'amour absolu sans réponse à un
vrai jeu franchement pierre il a
toujours eu le sourire il a toujours
hyper bien pris l'événement ils avaient
vraiment envie de s'en sortir et c'est
déjà ça joue quand même vachement et ça
permet de se projeter justement dans le
futur et se dire ok bon là il est dans
le bon état d'esprit donc on a envie de
donner envie de se battre pour que tout
se passe bien et puis après on a
construit plein de choses tous les deux
et il ya les voyages
voilà il ya les voyages vous nous
raconter parce que franchement est le
tranquille la vie on y voyage vivent au
real il voyage pas mal
ouais mais alors du coup on en a fait
que cette sa cause du come in may
mais du coup moi j'ai pas pu tous les
jours y trois semaines c'est vrai et on
est content pour des parties en
septembre 2019 du coup et on s'est lancé
dans un tour du monde va absolument
dingue mais on a commencé par l'amérique
du sud puis l'océanie on va traverser la
nouvelle zélande en tandem enfin voilà
on s'est fixé des petits défis un peu un
peu marrant quoi et c'était super moment
donc voilà j'ai des trucs comme ça
bon voilà que qu'ils soient sur ses deux
jambes ou pas en fait je m'en fous en
tous les cas jouer franchement on s'est
rencontré il ya un quart d'heure vous
êtes un soleil les chants et les mois
rien moi je suis un sourire il se passe
rien on n'a pas gardé mon anniversaire
donc c'est donc comme mollo là c'était
con c'était lundi ok le mieux c'est
quand même moi je vous ai appelé je vous
envoie des messages m'avait répondu il
n'y ait pas décrocher ce que c'est moi